hello everyone I hope you're all having
a wonderful Saturday because we're back
at the 1970 pomade America intra zonal
tournament it's around 18 and we have a
German Grandmaster aboveground woman
facing a Bobby Fischer with the black
pieces so what to say a bit about this
game before we check it out and you
don't talk a little bit about the
players we do have a nice photo
challenge so you know in preparations of
the of this entire series and the
candidates matches that will follow at
the palm of America inter-zonal
here we have it the one and only now you
have to say who it is that's how the
photo challenge works best of luck to
everyone now let's check it out Wolfgang
woman luck we've already said German
Grandmaster but not only a German
Grandmaster he also had a professional
career as an accountant so I mean what
what a party animal and he won a lot of
first places in 1970 and the events
leading up to 1970 were probably one of
his best years he won a lot of first
places in international tournaments here
he qualified for the inter inter zonal
tournament as you'll see later but you
might already remember as we did show
the final standings in the first couple
of videos
he will qualify for the candidates
matches after the polymer painter zonal
and this will be one of his best
achievements ever but one of his most
interesting aspects is that he is an
acknowledged how I said he is considered
to be one of the the greatest masters of
the French defense in the world and he
has written many many books on it under
French defense and he defeated many
stronger grandmasters one of his most
notable games is his victory over over
David Bronstein in 1977 in Italian in
the French defense but also as he is now
playing against Bobby Fischer ten years
ago in 1960 in Buenos Aires he defeated
Bobby Fischer with none other than the
French defense and exclusively if
someone played efore against him he will
play the French defense and that's one
of the games I will probably cover after
we finish DePalma the America
inter-zonal tournament you know just for
fun so that being said
there is already a d4 on the board but
it's quite all right as d4 is the first
move that was played in this game so a
woman goes for d4 you know he does have
the white pieces here but as Fischer
will most likely go for Eve or perhaps
he would maybe enjoy the black pieces so
he would go for the fringe defense
against favor a bit more but okay Knight
to f6 c4
we have c5 Fischer goes for the benoni
d5 now we have e six the modern
variation of Knight c3 we have captures
captures and d6 so everything standard
here efore g6 immediately and now Bishop
to f4 and here we have a six i always
useful move not allowing any Knight b5
business preferring b5 and you can you
can go push up the g7 immediately there
is no no problems here that this will be
any sort of a threat because here is not
going to a5 check but rather Knight
captures on e4 and this will be fine
after you attack the defender of the d6
square this exponent will simply attack
the knight and black is much better here
but okay eight-six by Fischer provoking
a4 as a woman does one figure to pull b5
with a four Bishop to g7 and the knight
to f3 castles
Bishop to e2 now comes the Bishop to g4
as the light square Bishop is probably
the most useless piece when you're
playing the benoni Fischer wouldn't mind
exchanging it we have castles rook to e8
and now comes h3 a move that could well
it could be definitely classified as a
mistake so if you're black here if
you're playing Fischer do you capture or
do you move the bishop put back what do
you do in this position neither of those
options rather you play Knight captures
on e4 and the reason this is possible
because the h3 with the idea of this
variation where the bishop is placed on
f4 notice that the bishop on f4 is
undefended
so what's the idea here if you capture
the bishop then you get Bishop captures
on c3 pawn captures and Knight captures
here the bishop is attacked twice the
queen is under attack you have to move
the Queen and now comes Knight captures
on e2 with check the rook is guarding
the knight King moves and now you can
simply either capture here and then
continue developing and black will have
an excellent position here and will be
up material
another thing after knife captors on e4
h captors in g4 was not played as a
woman sees that this will not simply not
to do i simply simply want to do so
tonight captures on e4 and here comes
Rock captures on e4 so yet again you
can't capture the bishop because this
bishop on f4 is now undefended Bishop to
g5 would an attack on the Queen and now
Queen to e8 so we have to you you have
to see all the way to here before we
actually decide to capture that pawn on
e4 with the night because now there's a
double attack on the e2 bishop and again
white shouldn't really capture here so
Bishop to d3 attacking the rook and now
comes the bush of chapters on f3 again I
have one of the most you had to see if
you ever decided to capture there and
there we have Queen captures on f3 you
don't want to capture the rook and give
up two bishops for a rook so Queen
captures and now comes look to be four
so Fischer has an outstanding position
he is up a pawn and everything is well
here we have rook a to e1 Bishop to e5
and now comes Queen to d1 preparing to
push f4 as the bishop on e5 is pinned
but it's not really a problem even if
you capture here on b2 and allow this f4
move you always have bishop to d4 check
and after King moves you can then move
the Queen but you would simply allow
White's too much activity even though
white would not regain material balance
so after Queen to d1 Fischer simply
plays Queen captures an a4 he offers
afraid of Queens and he's satisfied with
the way things are Queen captures rook
captures and now comes f4 push up to d4
check King moves and not nice to d7
simply preparing to develop pieces rook
to e7 and now if you check out the
position you can see that Fischer has
seven points woman has five points so
Fischer is up two points about omen has
a bishop pair and a very active rock on
e7 so is this compensation enough I will
just have to check check it out Fischer
was
Knight to f6 he offers the b7 pawn and
okay
rook captures some b7 reducing them the
material difference to only one point
and now not going
for night captures on d5 to allow f5 and
if the F file opens then white will have
sufficient compensation you know for the
material but after Luca rope to be 792
h5 by Fischer he doesn't go for for this
capture and now he's threatening night
the g3 check with the idea of capturing
the exchange here King to h2 and now
comes Bishop to e3 attacking the f4 pawn
and here the f4 point is attacked three
times by the bush by the night end by
the rook so the most obvious idea g3
does not work here because now you get a
rogue before you attack the bishop here
and if the bishop moves then rook to d2
will be very unpleasant so I have to
loop the d1 defending it now you get
Bishop to have two attacking the g3 pawn
that was so conveniently pushed to
protect f4 g4 and now knife captures on
f4 again black is doing excellent here
so after Bishop to e3 we have Bishop to
e2 attacking the h5 Knight Bishop
captures on f4 Bishop captures an f4 end
and now rook captures on f4 again not
allowing Bishop captures night because
the rook and f1 would be undefended so
we're up to b6 attacking the d6 pawn we
have rook captures Bishop captures and
now rook to d8 Fischer again offers a d
a6 pawn because he doesn't want to allow
woman to capture the d6 pawn and create
a very strong pastor here Bishop
captures an a6 and now comes King to g7
Bishop to b5 Oman wants to play Bishop
to c6 to protect the d5 pawn so when
Fischer attacks it with via Knight f4 or
Knight f6 the pond will be defended and
then the rook can move so King to f6
Bishop to c6 King to e5 Fischer improves
the position of Ace King
we have rook to b7 now attacking the f7
pawn and Fischer goes rook to f8
defending it
we have rook to e7 this comes with
chicken finger plays King to d4
we have rope to these seven attacking
the d6 pawn and here it seems like
Fischer doesn't really have a good move
here if he goes back to defend the pawn
then again can a rook to e7 check and
Fischer would have to go back
but after up to d7 attacking the pawn
there is one move woman missed and
Fischer plated so feel free to pause the
video here and
the crushing move that instantly wins
Fischer the game so there you have it I
will give it a couple of seconds for if
you want to decide whether to do it or
not as usual so for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
have successfully continued Fischer's
legendary winning streak and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
Knight to f6 was the move played and it
was in this position that Logan Oman
German Grandmaster and an accountant
resigned the game why did you resign
well it's pretty obvious once you see it
if you don't see it it's not very
obvious but once you see it it's very
obvious after rocky after sandy 6 King
to e5 traps the rook Knight is guarding
d7 Rocky's guarding in the 8th the rook
has nowhere to go the bishop is blocking
the rook so here you would simply have
to give up the exchange and with four
points each a rook will be better than a
bishop here and even if you don't
capture after Knight to f6 if you play
something like what rook to b7 may be
blocking rugby 8 not so black can't
attack the pawn again black can pretty
much choose what to do here Knight
captures on d5 the most obvious idea
Fischer will now be up two points and
now you can't play an endgame being down
two points against Fischer so that's the
game
round number 18 of the palm of America
inter-zonal tournament of 1970 both
young woman versus Bobby Fischer I do
hope you enjoyed it and that you're
enjoying the coverage of the Bobby
Fischer series so far I would like to
thank like Union Robin Moret and char
CUDA for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon
with around 19 of the 1970 palma de
mallorca inter-zonal
thank you all and I'll see you soon